each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
it started this is actually our third
annual workshop on advances in quantum
algorithms and devices I'm very excited
that we have this yet again and we have
lots of wonderful speakers lined up this
morning and this afternoon so thank you
all for coming again to the faculty
summit into our workshop we always love
this week in July when everyone's here
it's a lot of excitement so so it's
great to see some faces back again and
some new faces this year just a couple
of notes will have to coffee breaks
we'll have a lunch the lunch will be out
where we had breakfast this morning when
you when we do have questions if you
could please use this mic to ask the
question that's really for I know we can
all hear each other but for recording
purposes we'll ask that use the mic so
that for later you know after the fact
people can also hear the question so I
think we'll just jump in and get started
our first speaker is rod van Meter and
he's going to talk to us about
distributed density matrices yeah thank
you um Burton you can't see can you I
just noticed why can you let's move this
over a little bit anyway so it's
customary for speakers to start by
thanking the organizers and I always
hate that because because the during
that 15 seconds you're thanking the
organizers people start to check their
mail and never come back and pay
attention to but since I am the first
speaker at the last day of things and
Microsoft has been so generous and
Kristin particular has been great about
getting a this whole thing organized I
really want to thank Chris de and the
the other Microsoft folks here for all
they're doing and say congratulations on
your the kind of visibility you're
getting as we saw in the in the talks by
Harry Shum and Peter Lee mentioning
explicitly the work that you guys are
doing I think it's great and I'm
thrilled near that Microsoft is doing so
much interesting work on things and see
so much future in this field we're
working in so
I'm a professor at keio university in
japan and I call my research group aqua
for advancing quantum architecture so we
have a couple of water related pictures
there for you today I'm going to talk
about distributed density matrix
management and over the last two and a
half days you're starting from dinner on
Tuesday night every time I've had a
conversation the amount of things I
wanted to put into this talk has
actually grown so I'm going to try to
blast through some stuff early on in
this talk where I'm just going to
mention some chunks of work that we've
been doing and if you actually want to
want to discuss those come find me later
at any of the the breaks during the day
and watch to talk about them and then
hopefully I'll spend most of this time
actually presenting a problem definition
I can't say I have a full answer to this
particular problem yet but I want to
convince you that there's an interesting
problem here that actually needs to be
solved and proposed several possible
solutions none of which really make me
happy let's see so as I said my group is
advanced in quantum architecture and the
overall area in which we are working is
distributed quantum computing
architectures including work on some
work on devices which is we've mostly
discontinued that was with yoshiyama
modeless group at Stanford some work on
workloads which figured into my PhD
thesis the better part of a decade ago
at this point some principles and tools
and the thing that ties it all together
is networks and that's really what i'm
going to be talking about today is
networks but i realized this slide I
made a long time ago now but I've
realized actually that a lot of the work
we've done in the last several years has
been about how to actually implement
quantum error correction efficiently
we're not really working on the theory
of error correction but we're working on
figuring out what what the constraints
are on machines to actually run it
efficiently and in particular focusing
mostly on the surface code let's see so
just to blast through some of the stuff
we've done recently some of you all have
seen the work on solid bake it day of
the first author of this was actually
yeah this is a phys Rev a paper the
first author was an undergrad of mine
and recently we've done some work on
designed for floating point adder which
was also done by an undergrad of mine
and a paper of mine on quantum computing
classical problem a classical computing
clumped on problem and about two years
ago now we had an article appear in
communication to the ICM that actually
made the cover on a blue a blueprint for
building a quantum computer which sounds
a little bit like I thought that was
sort of a grandiose title but was
actually suggested to us by one of the
reviewers so I was happy to adopt it and
go and for those of you is a couple of
you all have asked since i live in japan
so would you read and write japanese and
you actually publish stuff in japanese
yes last year i published my first paper
actually in japanese and after i wrote
the first draft and gave it to my
co-authors that came to acting to me and
said we had no idea what you're talking
about so by my empathy for non-native
English speakers writing research papers
in English went way up during the
process of writing this paper I can tell
you that it was already high though so
today we're actually going to talk about
quantum networking which is an area that
i published a book in last year there's
a copy somewhere but you know that's I
guess in some sort of superposition
state between Martin's office and Dave's
office at this point did you find it
okay good but I think Microsoft should
buy more copies personally so in
networks we're talking primarily about
repeater quantum repeater networks where
the goal is to create shared
entanglement end-to-end that we're going
to use for some purpose or another i
divided the set of things that you might
like to do with such a quantum network
into essentially three areas one of
which is distributed cryptic
cryptographic functions one is sort of
cybernetic operations where you're
talking about physical interaction of
the quantum state with the environment
in some way you can call those all sort
of sensor operations and then there's
just plain digital distributed
computation there are a number of things
that have been proposed in this area I
have a student right now who's actually
looking at quantum Byzantine agreement
there's leader election quantum key
distribution which is probably the
single most famous set of things up here
fall sort of on that boundary between
sensor networks and distributed crypto
function because in fact what it's doing
is it's testing the environment for the
presence or absence of a of an
eavesdropper some other sensor things
including some interferometry and clock
synchronization and the like and blind
quantum computation is actually one of
my very favorite things these days if
you don't know much about blind
computation I would encourage you to
take a look at it these things up here
in the upper circle are attractive to
people in the systems world because they
reduce our dependency on computational
complexity in one-way functions and
publicly key cryptography and things
things of that nature I do have to
always sort of encourage the physicists
to be careful about saying but it gives
us perfect secrecy because I'm a systems
person and you know systems people all
know that perfect secrecy doesn't exist
in the real world so this set of overall
functions and whatnot the crypto
functions are largely what i would call
low beam with operations the sensor
networks are high to very high bandwidth
and again also the distributed
computation turns out is also high to
very high bandwidth where this is sort
of both the low bandwidth stuff you
could make do with creating entanglement
entangled states between n nodes at tens
of qubits per second whereas for some of
these functions down and through here
you might need as much as 10 to the 11
Bell pairs per second and in a network
which is a very large number any
questions on this stuff before I sort of
before I move on this is just sort of
setting the stage here you know
let's go in networking stuff we have
also published a recent set of things
path selection for quantum repeater
networks how you choose a path through a
network fault tolerant operations for
blind quantum computation classification
of attacks on the quantum repeater
network itself and one that we're just
about to get accepted accepted I hope
how to actually do high speed quantum
networking using a containership
literally physically a containership the
kind of thing that moves your nikes back
and forth between here and China ask me
about any of these things later if you
want a couple of things that we are
working on right now heterogeneous lee
encoded Bell pairs so take a bell pair a
physical bell pair split it apart take
one of the the component members of the
bell pair and encoded in the steam code
and one of the belt players and coaches
in something like the surface code and
we can use this for quantum internet
working between nodes or types of
networks yeah this work and the next one
that I'm going to talk about real quick
we're done by a few of my undergrad or a
few of my students Howery on the right
she's now working for as a programmer
for a gaming company the other two are
about to finish their PhDs one with me
and one at the University of Tokyo and
the basic result of this we're still in
the process of visualizing this this
data is only a few days old we're still
need quite a bit of work on this but the
basic result we've come out with so far
is that if you want to do this that it
seems like the right scheme is actually
going to be to take those physical Bell
pairs do the do the encoding into error
correction schemes and then take sets of
those and do purification on top of the
logical encoded qubits seems to give us
the the the best sort of output rate and
the best use of resources another one
Martin was asking me about network
coding stuff the other day and when
Martin and I actually I got to have a
talk how many of you all here are
familiar with the basic concept of net
coding either classical or quantum only
a few okay so the basic idea is you've
got this graph that you can use for
communications and what you would like
to do is you would like to communicate
between the upper left and the lower
right and the upper right and the lower
left but there are resource conflicts on
this you can't do it in one single use
of those set of links unless you act
intelligently in some way or another
this is a well-known classical result it
has moved into the quantum domain in the
last few years and my former student
Sato who has finishing his PhD at the
University of Tokyo worked out how to
actually do this with quantum repeaters
and how to actually get this to work but
still all of that work was done with
pure States and in recent the last year
or so colouring my master's student she
has extended this to actually work with
mixed states and Sato is now finishing
up a paper on this in the process and
that allows us to determine if you had
an error on this Bell pair and an error
on that Bell pair what would sort of the
end result be which of the sets of
output states would actually have an
error in them and this particular
configuration it would be this Bell pair
winds up with an errant but not the
other felt bear found some interesting
things out of that all right that's sort
of everything in 10 minutes that's most
of what my group has done in the last
three or four years if you want to talk
about any of that you know please come
find me afterwards let's talk about
distributed density matrix in management
which is what I want to spend most of
the rest of this time talking about what
exactly is a density matrix anybody care
to venture an opinion on what a density
matrix actually is we could be here for
a while right this one actually I've
been out giving this talk off and on for
the last year and every time I go
someplace and give this talk I'm
actually most of the time we've done it
with a whiteboard rather
with slides but every time I've given
this talk it's gone differently because
the audience seems to come to this with
different preconceptions of what they're
expecting or what they what they
understand from the system as a whole so
and sometimes we get stuck on this slide
and spend 20 minutes or on this topic
and spend 20 minutes on this of course
mathematically we all know this is the
way you write it down it's a statistical
construct that represents our
understanding of the state right I am
right out the numbers it may look
something like that or it may look
something like this which is your this
is the written in the bell basis this is
actually what comes out of some
experiments from REM phase group in the
last couple of years right so what is it
though we're used to writing this symbol
Rho and maybe some some numbers but you
don't really think about what it really
is ok what is it what is a density
matrix well if you are going to actually
calculate this density matrix it
actually exists as a data structure in
memory of some machine or another
somewhere right where that machine might
be that machine might actually be a
graduate student with a pen and a piece
of paper but it exists in the memory of
a machine somewhere what we are worried
about is not not the size of the problem
which is sort of automatically one of
the things you think about when you're
thinking about quantum states but we're
dealing primarily here with two qubit
states Bell States and so the size of
the matrices themselves is not large
we're talking about four by four
matrices 16 complex numbers it's to earn
fifty six bytes like no big deal the
problem is not the size of it the
problem is being able to use these in a
timely and consistent fashion Nathan's
giving me a puzzle book comments
questions where's the mic
you can you decide what you talking
about sup it sounds like you're talking
about software simulations of quantum
systems rather than taking a look at
quantum systems so I'm just trying to
understand what what it is what's the
problem and what are you dressing we're
going to get there momentarily I am
interested in operational behavior of
quantum repeater networks so the real
world when we start deploying quantum
repeater networks that's being the
planet how are these going to behave how
are we going to drive them how are we
going to make decisions inside inside of
these systems now the way you actually
get this the way you actually create
this object of the density matrix you've
got some sort of experimental apparatus
that's controlled by some sort of hard
real-time system that creates an
entangled belt pair of some sort out of
this you run some experiments you
collect a bunch of data at this point
it's just raw data this is all sort of
soft real-time control of your of your
experiment and then sometime later your
graduate student Alice she comes along
you know after after dinner and hanging
out with the other students in London oh
wait but I've been told that Eddie far
he doesn't and doesn't actually like God
Alice so we'll put Alice in the in the
witness protection program I had dinner
with Dave making the other night and he
said that when he gave a talk in front
of you one time you said that's the only
time I've ever liked a talk that
involved Alice and Bob right at any rate
so Alice comes along and her job or our
anonymous a graduate student comes along
and her job is actually to process this
raw data into this density matrix which
exists now in the memory of her laptop
sometime divorced in some physical place
divorced from the actual experimental
apparatus itself
all this is fine if your goal is this
your goal is to create a nature paper
right you don't care when when the
density matrix gets calculated as long
as it looks nice enough to a period in
nature um but if the goal is if our
state is actually distributed the
control of the system must be as well
this gentleman is named Bob he's a
television personality in Japan but
Alice has her own device and Bob has his
own device and this distance may
actually be kilometers tens of
kilometers and their relative
understanding of what's going on can be
out of date by that distance divided by
the speed of lightning now if we are
planning on using this for real
operational work and repeaters those
distances are significant particularly
if we want to do this all the way
between Tokyo and Seattle what's the
round trip between Tokyo and Seattle
round trip time three mega meters let's
see it's about a hundred milliseconds
right so it's actually 10 to the let's
see three times it's about a hundred
milliseconds so whatever that is nope
actually because we're doing this in
optical fiber it's too right so it's
about two-thirds of this as a complete
aside by the way or the people I work
with are our internet people and their
perpetually worried about wanting to
create a lower latency internet between
places and my answer is rather than
trying to rear out things what they just
need is they need fast or light the
problem is that in fiber you're only
getting seventy percent of the speed of
light you could do this in other media
and potentially get quite a bit of
savings on them anyway that's an
entirely different talk
something like that yeah what we want is
we want to make real-time use of this
density matrix to actually control our
set of operations and hear the argument
broke down one time when I was giving
when I was giving this are this talk
because one of the physicists in the
room objected and said well but the
density matrix is just a statistical
construct you can never use it to talk
about an individual state you can only
use it to talk about a large collection
of state so a large ensemble right I'm
going to build a network I'm going to
have to figure out how to control it
some of that control is going to be
statistical we're going to have to use
these density matrices for this stuff
Nathan's of your alpha is broad what's
your definition of real time slightly
less faster than that right well that's
going to depend on a number of elements
of the behavior of the repeater itself
if you are dealing with any memory that
decays then real time means fast enough
so that so that you can deal with that
decoherence in some in some way shape or
form so some of the technologies we know
they're the flux cubits and the like
they're finally getting up close to a
millisecond others or longer but you
need to be much faster than that
moreover since the number of memories
were talking about in each of these
individual nodes is still relatively
small and you are waiting on
acknowledged acknowledgement messages as
to whether or not things like
entanglement succeeded you need to deal
with that at sort of round-trip latency
time levels and you would like to be
able to do some of that stuff faster so
this is relatively hard real-time stuff
for some of these operations actually
the guy that I was working with while I
was a Duke Jung sang Kim believes that
the single biggest hurdle to actually
making repeaters physically work is the
need to distribute a very high precision
clock between the nodes we're very high
precision is 10 to the minus 12 or
something like that I think
going to trust the experimentalist solve
that problem and if the system's level
why I care about is primarily going to
be on the order of microseconds Nathan
did you want to kick something in there
he was started to say something too
nevermind nevermind different discussion
so what we are doing is we are depending
on the predictive power of the density
matrix to represent probable outcomes
for individual quantum states individual
ones because we're dealing operationally
with one state at a time so how many of
you all are familiar with the the
operation of repeaters a few okay basic
idea we're going to show you sort of the
basic idea here three stations two links
each of those arrows is a qubit first
thing you have to do is you have to
create entanglement between the two of
them and forgive my fabulous PowerPoint
artistry what we want to do is we will
actually want to create entanglement
that spans this whole distance from
station 0 to station two or however many
hops we're dealing with the way you do
that is by doing what's called a bell
state measurement in the middle and then
communicating the classical results out
when you have done that once this
operation has completed you now have
entanglement that spans this distance
this is called entanglement swapping it
causes a decline in the fidelity of your
end-to-end state so what we must do
afterwards is purification and in the
purification operation you take two or
sometimes more Bell pairs that cover the
same distance you that's being the same
the same pair of nodes and we are going
to use one of those Bell pairs to test a
proposition about the other Bell pair
and if the test succeeds then then then
our confidence in the state of that of
that Bell pair increases so what you do
local operations at both ends measure
out those qubits at both ends you lose
that entanglement there and when it
succeeds you are left with higher
fidelity
so this the basic process of creating
the entanglement the entanglement
swapping and the purification or the
three operations you need to actually
build repeater networks let's see the
way you get to longer distances if you
want to go from tokyo to seattle or
someplace you begin with the the initial
procedure proposed by wolfgang doer and
hans briegel is what they call nest
entanglement swapping and you can do
this a stage at a time you take your for
one hop belt pairs and turn it into two
to hop Bell pairs and then from there do
entanglement swapping again and you get
to 14 hug bear and you can repeat this
process so here's our conceptual
hardware again as I mentioned earlier
the distances we're talking about here
on the order of tens of microseconds or
tens of kilometers and we are going to
need some sort of control mechanism at
each of these nodes and each one will
wind up with a copy of a density matrix
that represents for each one of these
two these quantum states that it's
actually sharing with someone else for
repeaters we're only doing this for Bell
pairs and so we only need to worry about
two nodes at a time for any of this
stuff so from this point forward we're
only going to deal with two or in one
case three nodes and doing this okay so
what's so hard about this I've been
talking for 25 minutes already I've got
about 15 minutes left to go we're just
now getting to the problem right what's
hard about this well in the laboratory
there are four simplifications that you
don't get to use in a real-world
operational network one of these I
already mentioned it to be earlier
graduate students creating density
matrices you know days after the
experiment is actually run can't use
that for operational work these systems
also often operate with a single
integrated controller but we're going to
wind up with controllers that are
distributed
across physical distances generally the
experiments being run today deal with a
fixed sequence of operations they're not
making real-time decisions about what
operation to actually conduct next third
point fourth point this is a generally a
well-known character I
well-characterized apparatus that
everyone is using in fact you spend a
lot of time tuning it and tracking it
none of these hold for operational
repeater networks in the real world this
is why it starts to get hard let's go
through a couple of these cysts these
let's go through an example here and
operationally what happens is that Alice
and Bob and Eddie are all going to have
a set of rules that they operate by that
they will decide whether it's time to do
purification or whether it's time to do
entanglement swapping so one of those
rules look like Alice and Eddie's rules
may look something like this if I have
to bail pairs with Bob of fidelity less
than 0.98 now I'm going to run
purification if I have one bell pair
with Eddie let's see and and that's
fidelity is above 0 point nine eight
then we're ready to actually use it from
some sort of application purpose that's
another rule you might have Eddie's
rules would be similar and symmetric to
that Bob's rules are slightly different
if I have to bail pairs with Alice then
we're going to purify but if I have one
bell pair with Alice and one bell pair
with with Eddie and they are both high
enough fidelity then we're going to do
entanglement slopping fair enough now
what you would hope is that this
decision to purify that if Eddie decides
to purify that alice is also going to
decide to purify what happens
if alice fires this rule the choice to
purify and eddie fires the rule to do
entanglement swapping well what you are
going to wind up with how could this
actually happen so we get entanglement
here then the next thing that happens is
Eddie and Bob succeed in creating
entanglement there Bob besides he's
going to do a entanglement swapping
moments later Alice get the succeeds in
getting notification of the existence of
a second Bell pair but perhaps due to
some timing constraint or to some
difference in their opinion about the
behavior of the system itself Alice
believes not that the fidelity is 0.98
she believes his point nine seven and
she decides to purify you're going to
wind up with a state that looks like
that it's going to be a 3 cubed
entangled state instead of the bell pair
you want this is junked right some
pertinence is pretty crucial to density
agreement about what the density matrix
looks like you'd like to have these
parties agree to what it looks like
that's exactly and they won't I mean in
general unless you do something pretty
radical but it occurs to me that that
itself is a communication problem so
there's a sort of a bootstrapping of
information issue here yeah so the the
very first time my collaborator
shaghayegh suzuki was working with me on
this the very first time he and i gave
this talk he actually gave it gave the
talk itself and it was at Stanford in
the lab of Yoshi Yamamoto and we had
students from Yelena lukovitch's group
and Hideo mabuchi was there and hit on
some his group and she gave us talking
and most of the people in the room were
just going and Hideo mabuchi looks at he
says wasn't this just a distributed
database synchronization problem yes
head Hideo gets it right he was the
first person in the room to sort of
understand what was going on but for
other people you know some people will
say well this is obvious
right others will say I don't get the
point what the problem is it sort of
varies the goal though is to create this
this shared understanding of what this
density matrix is going to be in a way
that allows you to make these consistent
decisions ideally without having to pay
roundtrip communication costs between
the notes because those round trip
communication costs between the nodes
cost you performance and if your memory
decoherence processes are significant
they may in fact make it impossible to
actually operate correctly if you're
talking about latency of 100
milliseconds between node here between
Tokyo and Seattle right it's not going
to happen so what we need to do is we
need to consistent the condition of the
bell pairs and the set of Bell pairs
that we are actually operating on all
the decisions must be made under those
conditions so why is this hard and I'm
starting to run a little short on time
here already here's a map of the
internet in nineteen ninety nine people
have pretty much given up on drawing
maps like this at this point beautiful
map each one of those nodes in this map
is not actually a node in the network
each one of the nodes in this map is
actually a tire network in its own right
which might look like that or might look
like that or might look like that so the
network itself is extraordinarily
complex it also spans extraordinary
distances and in the process of doing
this in order to create a connection you
are going to wind up having to choose a
path through through this network of
some sort and in fact it's going to wind
up being largely a path of strangers
okay
so Christo decides that she wants to
connect to Matthias how is she going to
going to succeed in doing this we're
going to run through New York and Boston
but Chris has never met any of these
people in the middle so how do Krista
and Matthias decide how we're actually
going to do this communication what is
the structure of the the network what's
the memory lifetime of things right
there are a whole bunch of unknowns
who's involved what the fidelity of
local gates is what the decoherence
process is at each of these nodes are
possibly the repeaters that are
operating here may decide oh I'm
probably going to have to keep this cube
it for a long time but my physical error
rate and process my physical decoherence
is too high so i'm going to encode it in
an error correcting scheme and like I
talked about right at the beginning with
the heterogeneous and tangled Bell pairs
that we were talking about that encoding
process is itself a noisy process and so
after you've done it you can then keep a
qubit for a longer time but you're
paying a penalty for doing it so you
need to exchange information about that
penalty you need to be able to describe
that to each other even how many things
like how many memories are other
available so the key principles for
actually getting this done Alice and Bob
or everyone in the in the the chain must
agree on the state that's actually being
created so what are we actually creating
that includes not just the desired state
but also the noise terms and not just
the fidelity because actually the shape
of the density matrix where you're off
diagonal terms arm what those are affect
the the success of the the the
purification process as well they must
agree on the creation time because
otherwise if you're talking about
decoherence processes it's impossible to
talk about them unless you know how long
the state itself has been sitting around
and they must share an understanding of
the time evolution of the state that
limits the there are choices of
operations it limits their freedom to
operate and as I said earlier they must
also operate on the same list of states
finally starting to see nodding the
audience I think
starting to get there I can think of
five ways to get there I'm going to go
through this very very quickly so that
we can have a few minutes for questions
here one way is to resent relies the set
of operations the second way is by
specification third would be by contract
fourth and the fifth the fourth and
fifth one the difference you got to kind
of pay attention to catch here
distributed computation based on local
monitoring so we're going to monitor
only nearest neighbor and then on top of
that we're just going to exchange ideas
about what we think is what was going on
or true multistage monitoring where we
actually do perform tomography on every
step of the way over every possible
distance in the entire set of things
generally when I talked to
experimentalists and I present this I
find that what's in their head is
actually resent realization so we take
those distributed control nodes and we
just combine them into a single node and
that single node controls every single
operation that goes on tells everybody
whether you're going to purify or
whether you're going to do entangle and
swapping or the like simple as possible
architecture it's not going to work at
10 microseconds per kilometer round-trip
time for large distances it's simply not
feasible we could treat every link
exactly the same this is in effect of
the way the network we are all using
right at this very moment works for in
terms of noise operators and everything
else what would be the quantum
equivalent of half of the physical layer
in this wireless network in this room
that we're using what would be the
equivalent of that set of specifications
and in particular we would find that
this is not going to allow us to deploy
links that are substantially different
in any sort of physical sense and the
set of up the the set of behaviors we
know depends not only on the technology
but also in the distance and the quality
of the fiber and whether or not they're
splices in the fiber and everything else
it
limit our ability to do them let's see
so by contract would be sort of similar
to specification except that it's
decided on a per connection basis I'm
not going to go through with this
because we are running a little short on
time here and the local monitoring as I
said you might include information such
as exchanging information such as I kept
dispel pair in a memory of this
particular type for this mini micro
seconds and that might then the other
guy can use that to calculate what the
fidelity of the outputs data is there
are a few more slides but let me go
ahead and skip to the conclusions here
on this don't know in order to actually
pull all of this off you're going to
actually have you must have the ability
to assess the the end-to-end fidelity of
the state's quickly this problem has
been giving us a headache in the process
of actually implementing simulations for
a year now and there are trade-offs in
the complexity versus the performance of
the the total operation and there are
some additional problems that we didn't
talk about including how you define what
the zero point is in time for various
operations which turns out to be
interesting and how to integrate it with
other types of operations as well
fundamentally out of those five possible
solutions that I are proposed none of
them really seem very appealing the
latter two in particular you wind up
consuming a tremendous amount of your
operational time to actually perform
tomography and monitor the the overall
set of the state finally an
advertisement just recently we held the
the first workshop on quantum repeaters
and networks I was part of the
organizing committee for that the second
one will be in Europe in 2017 Rob
through from from Josiah's group Geneva
is is going to be the general chair for
it next time and this is my group of
people this figures figures actually a
little bit old this picture is
but us having some fun and finally let's
not all forget we are now at about 90
hours out from Pluto so in case you need
a little bit of perspective right the
New Horizons probe headed for Pluto is
moving at 31,000 miles per hour and it
will be it's about three million miles
out from Pluto right now and on Monday
or Tuesday will be getting some
fantastic pictures that's real that's
four and a half hours of one-way latency
to any questions we are at 40 right now
so crystal will have to take charge and
chop this off wherever she feels
necessary so you're trying to build a
communication system that communicates
yeah quantum things right and you have a
communication problem and polluting your
communication system what a surprise is
what you're trying to say well what I'm
saying is I mean you've got means for
teleportation all over the place in fact
you know it's the whole point so isn't
there can't you come up with some way to
bootstrap the whole thing I mean you
know sort of say well I need to
communicate better information about my
density function my density matrix so I
have this ability to communicate its
imperfect but well even to make
teleportation work you need the
supporting classical information to
catch up to it oh that's true yeah
that's true and in fact teleportation
the the entanglement swapping itself is
in effect a form of teleportation right
but of course one of the big things you
want to do is once you've created the
end end entanglement a use for it is to
teleport data back and forth yeah any
way that I think you get my point I mean
there ought to be some some way to
improve the estimate of the density
matrix iteratively using the same
machinery you're trying to in the in the
words of the great Robert Heinlein there
ain't no such thing as a free lunch I
writing any other
one or two more questions let's see
who's up next very um nine-time Barry
you want to come on get hooked up any
others so one of the things that I
think's interesting about this problem
is that there's a natural exploration
exploitation trade-off in that as soon
as you set up a network between
untrusted people you can spend time
either calibrating the devices or you
can spend time trying to communicate so
it seems like a near bottomless problem
in terms of you can focus a lot of them
device characterization and reference
frame sharing or you could spend a lot
of time and trying to optimize your
protocol have you thought about what's
the simplest approach you can you can
take that's actually meaningful and
analyze that I think that's what we're
trying to do and in a couple of the
slides I skipped over right there at the
end there's an very very rough back of
the envelope estimates for how much time
you would wind up spending doing
tomography in the different schemes that
I proposed the when I've talked about
doing the distributed computation which
I favored for a while when we first
started working on this the you know I I
talked to some people and they were just
going to know you can't do that the
complexity of dealing with that
computation is just going to be beyond
anything you can imagine there's no way
to make it really work so we shifted
directions and they said well we're
going to have to do the end and
monitoring that we're going to have to
do end end tomography if you do that
you're going to wind up spending a
tremendous fraction of your end end
bandwidth on the tomography itself to
figure out whether or not you're
actually building states you can
actually use it's a notice of its a
substantial trade-off and we don't have
them it's going to be to a certain
extent parameter dependent of course but
we don't yet have an answer to that
that's what we're trying to get to with
this any luck I can keep answering
questions any other thought you were
talking to me yeah all right let's see
all right Martin's got a question game
I'm like ah ha there we are do you run
it you want to cut it off or you want to
let mark me ask this question I'm
curious a do you envision to use the
network 4.2
point mainly or the envision a scenario
like in classical optics ofdm where you
can have a frequency encoding many
participants communicating the network
the same fiber but addressing different
frequencies to do it DC Talk are you
asking whether an individual link could
be multi-drop yes it could be all of the
models of everything we have looked at
so far all assume to two parties in the
in the actual on each individual link
but some of the things that the kinda
mota and Bill Monroe did with the cube
us stuff you could actually have
actually sort of a multi drop protocol
it could be done yeah could be I think
you're on Krista anything else howson